c'est par un tweet que le président
mexicain andres manuel lopez obrador à
informer ses concitoyens qu'il avait
attrapé l'aco vide mes symptômes sont
légers ajoute un blu comme on l'appelle
au mexique je suis sous traitement est
optimiste comme toujours nous allons
tous nous en sortir sa ministre de
l'intérieur olga sanchez a donc pris le
relais pour la conférence de presse
matinale du président elle affirme qu'il
va se rétablir rapidement et qu'il doit
être clair qu'il exerce pleinement ses
fonctions de président et quelles avec à
l'arc la sentra un plein aux airelles
scission dans une capitale encore plutôt
déserte à cause de la qu'ovide la
nouvelle fait la une des journaux mais
elle n'a pas surpris grand monde
c'est lamentable dit cet homme
lamentable important il a bien cherché
parce qu'il ne met pas souvent le masque
il se promène toujours par ci par là la
dernière sortie publique du président
remonte au 24 janvier dans un événement
à san luis potosi et comme à son
habitude pas de masque même si les
distances sont quand même respecter s'il
ne prend pas les mesures nécessaires dit
cette femme
comment voulez-vous auprès nos sérieuses
qui nous diffère
le président mexicain est un de ceux qui
a tendance à minimiser la co vide et ses
conséquences sur le peuple et l'économie
sont payés parmi les plus touchées et
les statistiques le montrent le mexique
a dépassé la barre des cent cinquante
mille morts de lakovic 19 au rythme de
plus de 600 par jour
il vient au quatrième rang des pays les
plus touchés après les états unis le
brésil et l'inde même carlos slim
un des hommes les plus riches du monde
n'a pas été épargné il se remet de l'aco
vide depuis une semaine maintenant
malgré ça la semaine dernière les
restaurants de mexico ont reçu
l'autorisation de rouvrir partiellement
mais uniquement à l'extérieur avec
distance entre les tables
jean-michel le prince serait du canada à
montréal